babies this episode of congratulations
is brought to you by the cash app you
want to get paid five dollars and also
give five dollars to charity do you want
to buy and sell Bitcoin instantly or get
your paycheck deposited right to the app
well then download the cash app because
all of the babies use it and I use it
elders and babies alike this why it's
the number one finance app in the App
Store we'll discuss it later on in the
show but download the free cash app for
iOS or Android now 65 the [ __ ] we do it
and you know what we're making some
changes here congratulations Studios
first of all I'm wearing sunglasses and
you can see that on the YouTube video
and it's cuz my future's too bright
that's why futures too bright now I'll
be taking them off in the middle of the
show cuz they're gonna be way too
annoying that's definitely true so yeah
but that's so it's episode 65 and I was
in dude first of all I was in [ __ ] I
had been to the South before and I've
been to Texas I've been to Jacksonville
Florida and I thought that that was the
south I thought when I saw Jacksonville
Florida I was like that's the [ __ ]
south not Texas northern Florida that
shit's southern okay you don't get much
more southern than that I want to
Alabama southern okay
that's the south everyone had an accent
in Texas you sometimes you hear people
just talking regular just hey what's up
what's going on hey how's everybody
doing in Alabama
everybody talks like that Huntsville
Alabama and Auburn hey Auburn get more
churches ah
Auburn has so many churches it's
un-fuckin'-believable you could walk out
of a church and you're in a new church
we get it we get it
hey you guys believe whatever you want
to but put some sandwich places in the
middle put some
[ __ ] Starbucks up put an Ikea put a
Home Depot don't need another steeple I
never knew what a steeple is anyway what
is this deep doesn't matter [ __ ] it
what's it matter what do words matter
I'm in one of those moods man I was in
Alabama and it was so him there were so
many [ __ ] dude there were so many
southerners that [ __ ] is a different
world it's actually a different world I
went there and there were people in my
audience with cowboy hats on my audience
with cowboy hats on
I get that Ron White's audience but my
audience my fans with cowboy hats to be
a fan of Chris D'Elia and still be
wearing a cowboy hat
that means I'm [ __ ] going global baby
that means I'm going global
it's making me happy I like different
people with different styles and
different areas in the country and also
beyond to be a baby
um but I was in Alabama and I was also
in I'm doing this thing where I forget
where the [ __ ] I've been hey butters
[ __ ] relax dude over here um I'm
doing this thing where I just I don't
remember where I've been I couldn't
remember two weeks ago that I was in
Pittsburgh Cleveland it took me about 20
minutes I had to not look it up I texted
my hope and [ __ ] but I couldn't remember
and then I went to Alabama and I can't
remember where else
Oh Nashville I had a Nashville show
Nashville is always a great time I have
a good time in Nashville and I did a
show there at the War Memorial
Auditorium which is a weird thing to say
War Memorial War Memorial [ __ ] that kept
[ __ ] it up memorial Oh memorial so I
did a show there and it was really fun
man it was all sold out I had about
1,700 babies in there and so I did that
and then I was traveling with my opener
he chipped his [ __ ] tooth did I talk
about this last time I would chipped his
tooth I think I did he chipped his tooth
anyway you guys know that if you follow
me on Instagram or whatever but he
chipped his [ __ ] tooth and then he
got a fixed the dude can't
[ __ ] speak he thought merry-go-round
was merry-go-round ah I said dude how do
you not know it's merry-go-round how
have you not seen it how have you not
[ __ ] paid attention and he said ah I
didn't really read that much I stopped
that goosebumps a idiot imagine reading
goosebumps and being like I'm done
goosebumps dude so many books of
goosebumps is that RL Stein is that what
that says RL Stein what a [ __ ]
name that is anytime you go by two
initials that's your name you know like
JP or RL you know what JP isn't that bad
because it happens a lot but RL those
that's us that's not a name dude JP is
almost a name in its own if your name is
RL though like what is it Ralph [ __ ]
Oh
what is it a guy Logan
Ralph Logan or some [ __ ] just glaze over
Ralph all round Stein look at him let me
look at the go-to let me look at what
our roster looks like Oh looks like a
guy that [ __ ] get so mad he blacks out
he looks like a guy that gets so mad
that he blacks out and then wakes up and
is like what's going on what everybody
go and didn't know what happened that's
the real goose bumps but uh so yeah he
and then I saw I was like what else do
you not know and he goes like this uh
first of all he didn't know when he dude
he told me this one he was like you know
when people say like yeah
while you're waiting he thought it was
why you're waiting ah why you're waiting
why you're waiting why you're waiting
we'll get a table yeah doesn't make
sense I was like dude the words don't
even make sense dude just think about
what the words would be people like stop
the goose bumps and then another one was
what was it merrygoround why you're
waiting
oh and might as well he thought it was
mine as well
I might as well yeah I might as well eat
it - might as well eat it what kind of a
dunce do you have to be and he was like
nah he's like that's usually how it goes
he was like that's usually how it was
he's like that's a common mistake I was
like no dude mine as well those words
don't even make sense together did you
just hear that dollar bill go that means
daddy made another [ __ ] few dollars
that's what that that's what that means
I got the [ __ ] sunglasses on cuz my
future's too bright and you know what
it's their blue sunglasses with blue
tint I'm stepping up my fashion game do
it and I know I constantly try step on
my fashion game but this time dude
undefeated sent me so much sauce it's
[ __ ] ridiculous
undefeated sent me so much sauce what am
I'm like I literally opened it up and I
go like this out loud to no one what am
I making a bowl of pasta that's what I
[ __ ] said what they sent me a [ __ ]
yellow hoodie a peach hoodie a [ __ ]
gray and white windbreaker black shirt
lime shirt dark green shirt white
crewneck sweater sauce some [ __ ] gray
slides like I'm walking around like I'm
Tony Soprano but the hip version dude
get out of here man they gave me peach
[ __ ] sweats too much what am I making
a bowl of pasta am i making pasta for a
[ __ ] family and some guests what the
[ __ ] oh and he's got shoes with tags
still on him hey dude that's crystally
over there he's got shoes with tags
still on him dude what the [ __ ]
joke's on him he still got the [ __ ]
the sticker down his leg that says l
forty times i guess he wears a large
what a joke he doesn't even know it's
cuz he has too much sauce it has nothing
to do with the [ __ ] it's because I
have got dude when somebody says to me
your tags still on I'm gonna look over
them Adam like the [ __ ] t1000 and say
I have too much sauce and then open the
wallet like the t1000 did with a heavy
seen this boy and there's gonna be a
[ __ ] bowl of pasta and I'm gonna say
have you seen this bowl he drips he
drips he drips he drips
dude their stuff I'm not even mentioning
I got a [ __ ] workout towel that says
undefeated on it sauce sauce at the gym
undefeated is some good [ __ ] though dude
yeah dude I'm gonna you know what I'm
gonna do I just gonna be bringing around
like a bullet past everywhere and then
and it will just play noodles with no
[ __ ] tomato sauce on it and when they
say dude you're gonna eat dry noodles
I'd look at them and I just lower my
gucci sunglasses and I go like this and
then they go like that they get it
because they see the [ __ ] full sauce
on my outfit I can't wait till I'm in my
40s that's what I can't wait till so I
could drip with sauce even in my 40s
people are like oh yeah you're trying to
wear what the kids were in [ __ ]
I'm young dude I'm young as [ __ ] I'm so
young it's ridiculous
give me a Tonka truck dude mine let me
line up my Micro Machines you know how
people say you're young as you feel
that's not true
but but I'm young I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm practically 13 dude I need braces I
got off the plane and when I got off the
plane first of all I watched Blade
Runner runner
bleh drummer or Blade Runner hmm Blade
Runner 2049 and it was cool it was cool
and then I started watching the other
Blade Runner and it stopped by the time
I landed that the earlier one you know
the one in 1982 which by the way still
holds so it looks amazing dude if you
watched Blade Runner now the 1982 2
version it looks like it was made last
year it's so crazy how they did that
it's so crazy how they did that and then
some movies from a 1982 look like they
were made by like just my cousin or some
[ __ ] but this [ __ ] looks so good
it still looks good by the way there was
like five different versions of them one
of them has voiceover it's terrible but
there's another version you can get
that's like the final cut or something
with no voiceover they took the
voice-over out it's way better
apparently that was what it was like
more like in the theaters but so I
watched a little bit of Blade Runner and
I was like in the whole like a future
could be real this could happen this and
that [ __ ] you know sci-fi [ __ ]
I love how sci-fi is like stuff that
could happen in the future it no it's
not though you know
oh really sci-fi it could happen a
really Star Wars say yeah so I was like
in this like serious thinking mood by
the way the one thing I like about the
Blade Runner movie you know what I
[ __ ] I always bothered me about all
of the movies that took place way back
when and then so like take Star Wars or
alien or like any of those movies that
were the [ __ ] back in the 80s but you
know when like they tried to make a
futuristic movie in the 80s they only
had the technology that they had in the
80s so they just basically just made it
like there are more computers not better
ones because they couldn't put the
[ __ ] cool sleek design on it like
Apple does now now we can plus now we
could because we have CGI right you
could make [ __ ] look like Holograms and
[ __ ] Minority Report where he's
moving [ __ ] around in his hands and [ __ ]
but but back then you just have like
chunky computers no matter what so if
you're doing a movie in 1982 about a mu
about a time in 2050 you still had to
use chunky computers with that [ __ ]
green screen you know what I'm talking
about with the green screen look like
broccoli and the [ __ ] words were all
lit up and then the cursor would just go
like this it would blink like this no
matter what even if it wasn't your 3000
because he didn't have the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that we could do we didn't have the CGI
or the the technology to make it look
good so so then the Star Wars used to
look like that and then they made the
Star Wars seven eight nine whatever now
that take place like a few years later
and it's just it it's like way advanced
and it doesn't make any sense because
it's like supposed to be like picking up
right where it left off and then the
[ __ ] just looks like it's and it's like
oh well that doesn't make sense in the
timeline because the computers were so
clunky and shitty four days ago and then
where this takes place [ __ ]
three days later even though it was made
forty years later in actual earth in
real life here we are in Hollywood the
[ __ ] looks so advanced I don't like that
but what Blade Runner does if you're
with me by the way you're a genius cuz
I'm gonna make it much sense but Blade
Runner did it the best way because the
new one two thousand forty nine which
takes place like 20 years after the
[ __ ] last Blade Runner they still
have that vibe of like the chunky
computers and [ __ ] it still looks like
it's this dystopian universe where like
they could use what they used all the
scraps that they could to make the
computers and [ __ ] it's just really good
the way they did it and the way they
picked up where they left off Congrats
to the [ __ ] director of the Blade
Runner 2049 that that [ __ ] is is awesome
so I was in this mood thinking about
this like [ __ ] [ __ ] where I was like
all cool like futuristic stuff and all
that and deep [ __ ] and like oh you know
you know sci-fi deep [ __ ] but then I got
off the plane and my opener who sits all
the way in the back cuz he sits coach
[ __ ] cuz that's what he deserves you
know I make him do it and he was like
hey man I saw Jumanji and I was like ah
oh yeah he said yeah it's [ __ ] funny
that's a guy yeah he said yeah Kevin
Hart's funny and the rocks really good
at doing those movies I just a great
he's a great movie star huh and I was
like yeah dude you know and I'm still
thinking I'm still in my [ __ ]
dystopian universe [ __ ] talking I
thinking about like you know robots and
how we can connect with you know how
machines will take over humans and this
guy's up here talking about how oh yeah
it's cool because the rock was you know
they they enter this video game and the
rock was like this little bitch-ass and
Kevin Hart was like the strong one and
then they had the reverse roles and the
girl was a guy and Jack Black was a girl
and now he's Jack Black and this and
then he's ended he got to all these
big-ass rhinos and I'm like hey dude you
got to slow the [ __ ] down you know when
two people are in two different moods
and they just don't meet and you just
can't do it and you're like and I was
getting pissed off for no reason but
this guy's talking to me about Jumanji
for way too long during the whole walk
to baggage claim he's talking to me
about Jumanji and how good it is now
here's the other thing I might watch
Jumanji and I think Kevin Hart is great
and I think the rock is great I love
Jack Black and that other girl looks
like she's funny but like at this moment
in time I'm thinking about robots taking
over the world and this guy's trying to
talk to me about how good you mangy was
and I'm like and I'm like bro you got to
stop
I said you got to stop talking about
Jumanji but then I realized I've done
that and it's just about moods that
don't they're like two ships passing
each other in the night man
right like have you ever [ __ ] been in
a bad mood and then somebody who drank a
cup of coffee walked around you just
wanna punch him in the [ __ ] face but
then sometimes that to you so I learned
something about like dude you just gonna
let people have the moods that they get
in you know you just got a [ __ ] chill
let the people have the moods that they
get in and you got to you got to kind of
stick why cuz here's the thing my opener
does that [ __ ] to me too like sometimes
I'll be like man how come I get so upset
when this happens and I'll be like I
don't know bro chill how long we have to
talk about this and I want to [ __ ]
fire him every time I don't know it's
like a wavelength though I know I talked
about this but I was thinking about this
too in comedy like all these Instagram
[ __ ] videos or that the people cut
together and make and think are funny is
like when your ex walks in and your
girl's got a bubble butt and like all
those stupidest [ __ ] [ __ ] videos
every single one that's just zero funny
it's like [ __ ] it's so bad and then
they go slow-motion and it's always the
[ __ ] it'll cut to a thing and a
close-up of it and then it's like I got
a bad bad I got the bad bad bad and some
girl will be shaking her butt and then
and it's so bad and everybody's so like
washed out and the eye lines are all
wrong you know but like those people are
doing what they see what they think like
here's the thing if you're funny you're
on a wavelength that funny people are on
right like here's a guy who's really
good at it uh what's that guy's name I
always forget his name on Portlandia
Fred Armisen that guy's just funny he's
on that wavelength
some of my buddies are that way Bryan
Callen Andrew Santino these guys are
just on that wavelength Bobby Lee
they're just funny they get it they're
on that wavelength now that transcends
you can be funny it's weird cuz like
funny is like a language but in a
wavelength but you can be funny to
people who aren't on that wavelength now
some people want aren't on that
wavelength don't get it but some people
who aren't on that wavelength you can
break through that wavelength and reach
them and they think it's funny because
you're showing them what's funny it's
like it's like it's like it's like it's
like a chef brings out [ __ ] clams and
like I don't like clams it's like we'll
taste these I made them a certain way
like okay and you taste me like ah I do
like it I didn't think I would but I do
that person showed you what it's like
right but since that happened since we
can we I say we like I'm on the
wavelength saqqaq but like since a funny
person if they're on that wavelength and
they break through to somebody who's not
funny and they think that that's funny
then they see what that is that person
who is not on that wavelength will be
like oh that's what's funny
and so then Instagram they have an
Instagram and they'll be like oh I'm
gonna make funny videos I'm gonna do all
the things that funny people do and then
that will be funny but that's not what's
funny what's funny is that wavelength
that they are not on and so these videos
that come out that are for the lowest
common denominator which is like when
your girl has a bubble butt and she
gives you some cash wink get a gun gun I
got the bad bad back I got the bad bad
bad that is not on that wavelength but
it's for all the other people not on
that wavelength that don't get that
wavelength it's for people that walk
around in the funny you in the universe
that just aren't on that wavelength that
are literally like this when it comes to
humor [ __ ] it that's how they are though
they might be a great businessman or
banker or a [ __ ] great in fashion or
whatever the [ __ ] even creatively they
could be a good painter but when it
comes to humor
I leaked out some shirt a leaking out
shirt that's how smart they are they're
not on that wavelength but the lowest
common denominator is the most they're
the most people so those videos on
Instagram become [ __ ] popular as [ __ ]
and then those people get 20 million
followers
I'm coming up I want the world to know I
did a 30 should it's leaking that's the
truth dude because they think they are
all those people not on there with like
they think bill burr is funny they get
it they think they get it they think
some of them think he's four they think
that you know the other guys I mentioned
Brian Collins funny BC Andrew Santino
and these [ __ ] you know but they're
not on that wavelength they're tasting
the clams from the chef that prepared
them the way that they didn't think that
they'd like them and it turns out that
they like them and that's the realest
[ __ ] I ever said man that's the real
issue
it's the realest should I have a rope
Domo crew [ __ ] nope mr. rule
should always that war Tupac you know
never not at war slept in boots and the
[ __ ] camouflage salute you know I'm
that wavelength yeah you walk around
[ __ ] it's leaking you did a duty you
know on the wavelength you think it's
funny but secretly you did duty okay so
our lads doing duty in your pants yeah
[Laughter]
you think you won the wavelength but
really duty leaking down your legs yeah
dude this is the [ __ ] that I say all day
long except not on the podcast and now I
have a podcast that's insane it's insane
I walk around my house all day long I
talk about this I talk about it with my
dogs I do too Park [ __ ] and I'll say
[ __ ] like you lived in the d-league
but now I have a podcast and sponsors
give me money because of it
hey America and people say all America
is going down the [ __ ]
America is terrible I'd rather live in
[ __ ] yada-yada than America oh really
that's interesting well what we've got
to do now is place my [ __ ] on your
forehead put my balls on your nose and
stick your tongue out so you can taste
my taint ha ha
America's
talking to a microphone and talk about
linking down legs with shits and make
money he this is disrespectful but this
is what you want man this is the baby
[ __ ] dude by the way I got to tell you
man the the the podcast has been going
really well and more and more people are
listening and that's what we want
and I just unscrewed this [ __ ] thing
and guess what I'm angry now sometimes
are gonna give you a behind-the-scenes
thing here a congratulations podcast and
we just did I I [ __ ] the microphone up
now I'm gonna go ahead and blame one
fire he's here and Ivan get rid of is
not here so let's just play him I even
get rid of and I gotta put this on here
again because it kept sliding and one
fire there we go there we go there we go
there we go we fixed it I fixed it these
are other things no I didn't break it
these are the [ __ ] things one fire
giving me [ __ ] like he's not one fire
Ivan gets rid of his not here how
ridiculous is that so yeah i guess i'll
do an adze huh right oh [ __ ] are they in
the books it went away episode 65 right
okay dude one higher he's helping me out
now [ __ ] the mic up but came through
with the ads me undies look you've heard
about you've heard me talk about me on
these and you know that I'm a big
believer in their product and I really
am that's all I wear and I'm telling you
right now as chris d'elia not as
somebody who's doing an ad so the
perfect balance of comfortable fit every
month they have new and exciting prints
that arrive at your door in a fun bag
it's very cool I love them they're the
most comfortable especially when I
travel it's the best because sometimes
when you travel or whoops or if you have
to let wear underwear all the time and
wear it all day they get sweaty me
undies it you don't get that it's just
comfortable all day long and even if
you're a sweat a fat sweaty pig it's
fine my undies uses lens ik micro modal
in their underwear it is a substan lease
or snatcher aliy soft fiber that starts
with beetroot trees and ends with the
most amazing fabric you've ever
experienced me undies has a great offer
for my listeners for any first-time
purchasers when you purchase me on did
you get to
percent off and free shipping me on DS
is so sure you'll love their underwear
they offer a 100% satisfaction guarantee
if you don't love your first pair you
get a full refund this is a no-brainer
get 20% off a pair of the most hunk of
the most comfortable on these
comfortable on these you will ever put
on to get your 20% off your first pair
free shipping a 100% satisfaction
guarantee go to my undies comm /
Congrats that's my undies comm /
Congrats this episode is also brought to
you by square cash babies if you haven't
heard we've all switched to the cash yet
me one fire
Ivan get rid of it's the simplest way to
pay people back friends family babies dj
khaled lil Uzi vert sending and
receiving money is totally free and fast
and most payments can be deposited
directly into your bank account in just
a few seconds and did you know that the
cash app lets you do way more than that
now you can even buy and sell Bitcoin
instantly get your paycheck deposited
right to the app pull money out of the
ATM with free custom cash card or use it
to spend anywhere you like you really
won't find a more useful finance app out
there I use it like I said my whole team
uses it to sign your cards and tweet us
a pic we want to see it's very cool to
see that stuff and all that of course
when you download the cash you have five
dollars goes to you and five dollars
goes to time's up Legal Defense Fund and
yet tweet us your pics download the free
cash app for iOS or Android now
everything okay okay cool
I asked one get one fire if everything
is okay because he was looking at the
video camera like it was [ __ ] up
anyway anyway dude
it's the sauce that [ __ ] made it all
happen today it's just the sauce that
made it all happen
[Music]
my mom my mom texted me I want to come
to your house and hang pics she's an
interior decorator and I have a bunch of
[ __ ] stuff that's framed around and I
just haven't [ __ ] hung up I know but
in my defense I've only lived in this
house for a year and a half and she sure
I wrote yeah you can come and she rushed
tomorrow okay oh sure it's tomorrow
okay I'll bring my baby daddy I said
okay you mean dad and she said I told
Dad you'd love that lol my mom's cute
and then she is cute she is cute one of
the things that she does that drives me
in saying though dude this is such a pet
peeve of mine and it's specific here's
what you'll do we'll be in a restaurant
the family or whatever or even if it's
just me in her whoever whatever she'll
be like hey Chris do you know what you
want and I'll say yup can't wait they've
got an open-faced turkey sandwich or
whatever the [ __ ] I'm gonna order I
probably wouldn't order that but and
then she'll be like oh okay cool you
sure cuz they have meatloaf ah anger I
already know what I want I already said
adamantly I know what I want why would
you throw a kink in the mix don't throw
a wrench into my [ __ ] plans I know
what I want and you're gonna confuse me
now cuz you know but I do like me love
oh [ __ ]
I was totally content and happy until
you suggested another meal why cuz mom's
always want to know they always want
they always want you and everyone else
to know around you that they know you
best cuz he likes me love what what can
I say so sue me
hey he likes me love my baby likes me
love what can I say so sue me
moms do that all day long that's a mom
thing and they do they know you're they
know their kid better than anyone they
do however if I want an open-faced
turkey sandwich and I said it don't
throw them [ __ ]
meatloaf monkey wrench in the plan um
yeah I don't know
am i [ __ ] hey how about this dude
uh no and I mean it dude enough enough
with the [ __ ] yodel kid how about
that
I don't you know what I don't make fun
of kids I don't like to make fun of kids
like specifically no making fun of kids
is fine
talking trash about him is I know this
kid fine great dude
CUDA everyone on board CUDA he was at
Coachella the yodel kid the yodel kid
was from an 8-second clip on Instagram
now is that [ __ ] it they're gonna
call it yodel chela soon [ __ ] bade
Shella dude suck my balls how about that
how about that
look this kid is too young to know that
everyone doesn't actually give a [ __ ]
about him do you not I mean he's on
stages like whatever song I love my girl
My Darling my darlin he doesn't know
that everyone in that audience would
[ __ ] you use his clothes to wipe
their ass with disrespectful to call him
yodel kid I mean dude by the way weddin
way --then the guy who brought him up as
DJ way --then dude how about this
there's no [ __ ] way the yodel kids
parents aren't racist - [ __ ] no way
there is no [ __ ] way you get out
there and you sang you sang for all the
people that love the lowered you sing
for all the people that love the Lord
cuz you got got a gift you can yodel and
you can sing with the best of them now
that's only for white people isn't it
now and then goes out there and he's
like huh I guess only white people sing
Yoli Oly Oly Oly none of you give a [ __ ]
about me but i don't know cuz i'm seven
hey how about you won't even more
disrespectful disrespectful they call
them the yodel kid the walmart yodel kid
dude people are like hey it's the
walmart yodel kid dude if someone called
me the walmart anything I'd kill myself
hey now not telling the little boy to do
that please don't but dude come on man
Walmart hey Walmart comedian Chris
D'Elia
hey Walmart comic Boy hey I'm the
Walmart Walmart comic boy how about
Walmart that name sucks
wal-mart two things that are esse basic
but yeah as parents are like remember
have fun have fun at school stay away
from black people and the kids like you
and lives in a [ __ ] posad oh man my
buddy was killing me the other day about
how he was texting texting this chick he
he does the road and he was talking to
me about this chick that was like trying
to meet up with him while he was hanging
out in this whatever city it was and
then she was like giving him the
runaround and he was there for like a
few days and then he didn't end up
hanging out with her and then she was
like well let me know your the the next
time you're back around town I'd love to
see ya and he was like he was writing
her [ __ ] like no you don't understand oh
oh wait no wait he wanted to he wanted
to like he was like let's hang out and
she was like I don't want to hang out
like late at night that's what it was
she's like I want to hang out late at
night but like let's grab a coffee next
time you're in town and he's like I
don't live here he's like he's like I
don't [ __ ] live here what the [ __ ] am
I gonna get coffee so he wrote her back
okay fine but if coffee goes well would
you consider moving out to LA with me
and that was the best response because
it's like it's like what are we doing
here you know he was like dude we're
either gonna have a fun time while I'm
here or we're not we gonna start dating
what the [ __ ] would he get a coffee with
a girl the next time he goes in that
area to tour it was so funny when he was
killing me dude he wrote yeah cool but
are you are you up for moving to Los
Angeles if the coffee date goes well oh
I gotta ask him what she said [ __ ]
after that oh it killed me that is kind
of weird though like all my friends are
touring comedians unlike of course a lot
of them like you know I mean guys guys
try to get laid you know is that okay to
say at a time like this
in this culture but you know some of the
girls whose guy was telling me like the
girls just want to like meet up and he's
like what's the [ __ ] point like I'm
gonna have some friend
in [ __ ] you know Portland Oregon
like you know what it reminds me dude
oh this is what it reminds me of there's
a song here god I love this [ __ ]
podcast I love doing it do it this is it
dude that's what it reminds me up like
just when a girl when a girl like that's
how you should have been when the girls
like hey well let's get a coffee next
time you're in town even though you
never visit [ __ ] Portland Oregon
dude Jadakiss really trying to [ __ ]
come up with that [ __ ] where he's it
rappers all have to have one of the s
insecure do it since a cure the bird
thing is we [ __ ] or what insecure
dude you know what the most insecure
[ __ ] what was it the most insecure
[ __ ] song rapper [ __ ] that he does
that it's not Jadakiss Jadakiss is this
[ __ ] by the way I love Jadakiss but um
[ __ ] I'm never gonna [ __ ] I'm never
gonna remember this I know futures on
the song my library uh [ __ ] I'm never
gonna find oh here it is here it is this
is sin secure is the most insecure
hip-hop moan of all time dude that kills
me he's trying to push it so hard
[Laughter]
by the way let me just tell you one
thing I think that's pushing t he is my
favorite living rapper right now
nobody's better than push it tape so I
[ __ ] love Pusha T for real if you're
not familiar with his music what you
gotta me the guy's so [ __ ] awesome
he's real hip-hop but he's still [ __ ]
but he does it it's like he doesn't
compromise you know he still comes
across being real hip-hop but also kind
of like bleeds over into the commercial
he's so [ __ ] good do it but this is
an insecure like he's like side I just
like real dope Ellis for real okay he
sells no cops go get him
I used to do this joke onstage what was
like there's so many documentaries or
like like what do you call it
series like docu-series are like like on
[ __ ] um the ID channel and shed and
like some of them were just like gang
members was like yeah you know I killed
this [ __ ] I'll beat the [ __ ] out
this [ __ ] I killed him I killed
iPhone 5 people and it's like oh stop
the documentary get him hey cops get him
like you know how are these guys not
arrested blocked it like booked as they
blurred out his face oh cool I had cops
interview the documentarian where did he
go help him you know I mean do it that's
[ __ ] crazy
that's literally [ __ ] insane I mean
some of these guys are I mean dude how
could you not [ __ ] arrestees guys
when somebody's guys
I mean dude these guys are on camera
talking about how there s insecure a lot
of you guys are you know I took about
submit Chand how [ __ ] is so [ __ ] and
how's this one guy keeps on coming up
with the [ __ ] Heat
he keeps tweeting me the [ __ ] most
[ __ ] [ __ ] how [ __ ] it to chase after
a bouncing ball how [ __ ] it to get
into the [ __ ] backseat of a two-door
car so [ __ ] some of you guys are like
how [ __ ] is it to have a coloring book
nope I can't help you guys I'm trying
but I can't help you some of you guys
are not on that wavelength dude hey
sauce with me this cult is growing dude
period people come up to me they tell me
they're a baby I love it I'm a true baby
I love it occasionally there's a guy
there are guys who come up to me like
somebody did in Huntsville Alabama that
said hey remember when you asked on the
podcast if you should have guests and I
said yeah he said I think you should and
then I get angry because he's giving me
tips and I don't want tips from that guy
and he's making it seem like the podcast
would be better if it was less me now do
I not like that guy no am i upset that
he said that yes
does he know no got off the plane the
other day some guy goes like this hey
man you look real tired what are you
doing oh I should have [ __ ] said your
chunky your fat I should have said that
cuz he was some people just think that
they it's like that you don't know me
[ __ ] you don't know me what
this [ __ ] [ __ ] ass actor this dude
on [ __ ] some [ __ ] he's been in some
good things but most he's just some
[ __ ] bitch-ass actor he came up to me
after my show and he was like hey man
that one part was hilarious about I was
talking about mmm I was talking about
Mexicans and then he was like it but
there's other no no he was like that one
part about robots is hilarious but you
shouldn't do that stuff about Mexicans
it's not as good do this stuff about
robots and I said I'm gonna do I'm gonna
do the stuff about Mexicans and then I
did it a whole bit about Mexicans and I
[ __ ] did it for Comedy Central and I
never did the robot stuff hey you
bitch-ass [ __ ] dude who do you
think you're dealing with who the [ __ ]
do you think you're dealing with
[Laughter]
you [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't want to tell
you what it was in it was an it was a an
actor that's in a lot of stuff but like
don't that's the guy he was nas and I
was to Park in that situation but that
[ __ ] I was like now I'm gonna do the
other stuff I know I got probably got a
robot bit too but like you know I mean I
just wanted to [ __ ] stick it to him
don't come to me with that [ __ ] man
I [ __ ] talked about what I want to
talk about there's no suggestion box in
comedy
I'm not [ __ ]
comic kid um how funny is that though
that that kid that what that yodel boy
is going to be 45 one day and the peak
of his career is gonna be the yodel boy
[ __ ] at Walmart and he's just gonna be
like some [ __ ] probably weird-looking
guy because everyone ends up being
weird-looking and that's it yo shut up
shut up doggies come here butters Sam
come here
I don't know hey hey hey shut the [ __ ]
up don't bark yeah but this cult is
growing man I'm trying here I don't know
what else I have to talk about oh I
guess we could uh you know what I'm sick
of here's something I here's something
here's something I want to stop having
to see basketball players walking to the
locker room if you watch basketball and
you love basketball now find out I don't
love basketball I don't love watching
basketball don't love playing it I don't
care about it but if but this [ __ ] and I
understand it's a marketing thing for
these companies and for these you know
but when I got a C James Harden walking
down a hallway in an arena with some
[ __ ] fashion like a blazer with a
hoodie under it and some Gucci pants and
flip-flops and be like ah there he goes
it drives me nuts when I got to see
what's the other guy the [ __ ] the
main guy who rest well muscle rest book
that guy when I got to see that guy
dressed like a [ __ ] like Chris Tucker
in the Fifth Element looking to go to
the locker room
hey dude what the [ __ ] and and then
other people or this guy was he Kevin
Durant with the
with a [ __ ] like a beat-up Sade shirt
and a [ __ ] and and jeans with like
polka dots on it or LeBron in like a
bright yellow hoodie with a puke green
blazer over it and like a Russell
Westbrook with some dressed like clark
[ __ ] kent if he was if he was in a
gay club you know like you're a
basketball player you could dress
however you want but the fact that they
turned this into a thing that when
they're walking to the locker room dude
these guys you're you're you're
idolizing the way these guys dress as
they're walking on their way to to put
on a uniform do you understand how
[ __ ] sheep that is you're you're
idolizing a basketball player who is an
athlete you're idolizing what he's
wearing as he walks down the hallway to
change into an outfit that 12 other guys
are gonna wear him the [ __ ] out of here
come on dude oh here's Russell Westbrook
and his [ __ ] green button-down short
sleeve shirt and pink tie and pants to
match his tie and thin belt and [ __ ]
loafers and glasses that don't have a
prescription in it hey come on dude it's
just like dress how you wanna but don't
like try too hard you know this coming
from a guy whose weren't [ __ ] teal
tinted gucci sunglasses while he's doing
a pi a podcast fine but I'm not a
basketball player I guess I am just a
comedian maybe I'm completely [ __ ] the
[ __ ] is that guy wearing on the right
looks like a Thundercat what
earth is that look look hold up this
walk from the parking garage to the
locker room was once just a walk now
that underground March go zoom in one
fire
now that under Grand March has turned
into an NBA runway as photographer
photographer slinger waiting to snap a
shot of the league's best dress like
what did this is basketball dude dude if
Idol I wish I like basketball so I could
hate this even more so I could be like
it's not for the [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
who do this this is about the sport not
fashion
imagine having to get dressed to go get
dressed as the appetizers are getting of
the outfit getting dressed to go get
dressed huh that's the stupidest [ __ ]
thing I ever heard you get dressed to go
get dressed
to go play ball say yeah kacang turn
around why you use your tall body facing
my body turn your tall body around
give me a stool I'm inside yeah all
right let's take some Twitter questions
huh you have any pulled up or no all
right [ __ ] Juan Hunter where is your
ideal log cabin located I'll tell you
right now right next to a coffee shop
right next to a coffee shop and a stage
with a microphone that's it doesn't
really matter I don't I always imagined
it somewhere in Idaho or Montana but I
probably [ __ ] hate those places I've
never been to each of those places but
tall wheat tall weeds and then a nice
little [ __ ] mowed out area where we
can just chill out and then a lot of
cabin with a step up and you walk in and
there's all that's very comfortable in
there though it's not like uncomfortable
like log cabins are you got like couches
and [ __ ] and framed pictures of me and
like you know lots of common lots of
[ __ ] and lots of great food what else
Hey
brought this up affordable what do you
think I have talked about this yeah
definitely a crutch at crunch hey
Kristin you might have thought about
this before but what do you think about
that one person who always had
cha-cha-cha when people are singing hi
birthday you know how I feel about that
dude you got a good old favorite happy
birthday and you we we figured it out
don't change it dude you don't add cha
cha cha dude I used to be yeah yeah I
talked about this I you see there was a
high school kid a girl in my high school
that would go wow I actually can't even
do without cringing she would go
cha-cha-cha but we shouldn't she would
do it oh my god very few this might have
been the inception of my podcast when
this happened when I was [ __ ] however
I was in high school and this chick who
was first of all made so much sense she
was an uh in the drama in drama now as
in drama too but you know me I wasn't
like one of those [ __ ] that was
like one chick one time was like I been
snapping in a character all day oh
really
you crazy are you a crazy person okay
cool catch you later oh you crazy person
one time she said [ __ ] in the in the in
the school play because she was yelling
and she was like I'm so sorry I don't
know why I did that I was just in the
character see ya see ya see ya see ya
we'll catch you later every time she
talked on in my head I went we'll catch
you later but this other girl would go
cha-cha-cha maybe you guys are noted so
this is what it is it's happy birthday
to you and then the other person
somebody some [ __ ] will go
cha-cha-cha and then go happy birthday
to you cha-cha-cha some [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ]
we'll go cha-cha-cha making the birthday
song about them okay they're making it
about them this is someone else's
birthday it's never the person whose
birthday it is all eyes are on them
anyway but some piece of fake rubber
[ __ ] we'll go cha-cha-cha after every
[ __ ] line but this girl used to do it
like she wasn't doing it
that it's one thing to be like
cha-cha-cha it's already cringe central
but she would go like cha-cha-cha I feel
it in my chest when I even do it and I
don't even want to do it but it would be
like happy birthday to you and she'd be
like cha-cha-cha
like she wasn't doing it wow it bothered
me that might have been the birth of
this [ __ ] podcast man and and any and
the other like the girl who snapped it
into the characters all day she would
laugh she'd be like oh she's so funny
for doing that no she's not she's doing
what everyone else does that thinks
they're different that really is just if
you're real different [ __ ] in your pants
during the birthday song happy birthday
to you it's Lincoln I made it about me
but at least is different dude don't
[ __ ] cha-cha-cha up a birthday it's
not your birthday do it on your birthday
your birthday you can do it one time I
saw a Russian family at a restaurant and
they were singing happy birthday I used
to do this in my hack too and never
really fit though and you know how the
places are like happy birthday to you
like it was a restaurant and the family
always joins in happy birthday to you by
the second one right the Russian family
sat there didn't say [ __ ] and as the
[ __ ] family was going you don't
realize if the family doesn't chime in
you don't know the kid's name so it was
just the waiters and waitresses sing and
they were like happy birthday and nobody
so they just they literally went happy
birth happy birthday the
happy birthday to you and the Russians
just watch the cake wa and I'm [ __ ]
hate it now I've never seen something
more Russian than that that is the most
they should have just literally went
happy birthday dear comrade happy
birthday to you you communists happy
birthday dear KGB member is that even
that was a Germany happy birthday to
Vladimir probably ha da da da
what was the [ __ ] other name that I
was just thinking of I don't remember
anyway let's see another one
I mean weird Madhu what's his thoughts
on a Greenwich oh nice dude that's what
you deserve
this guy just sent me uh some a Jif of a
girl playing Jenga in a back yard and
she undid the what an idiot dude you got
to retweet that from the pot from what
yeah big big Jenga Oh big Jenga yeah
yeah that's that's some stupid [ __ ] big
Jenga if you play being big Jenga yeah I
see it at the bar right hey Chris Leah
what are your thoughts on grown-ass
Cudas playing giant Jenga at the bar
yeah but I don't I don't think it
scooted to play that though that's why I
didn't say it but I think it's just dumb
like this girl he said that you forgot a
retweeting from the park as a captain
Parker Scout but this chick the gif of
it she took out the big Jenga brick and
she like posed with it to the camera and
as she did it the Jenga fell over on her
[ __ ] girl face right on her [ __ ]
face come on dude she does
that you deserve it you deserve it at
what point are we gonna stop feeling bad
for people you got hit in the face you
deserve it you play big Jenga first of
all all right fine you play big Jenga
fine that's really not the end of the
world but you're gonna yeah yeah look
the things topple over the whole name of
the game is toppling it over and she
just looks over and hits from the
[ __ ] face do it
that's it you deserve it
little Jenga
okay I guess but don't try to change the
[ __ ] that already works see that's the
thing oh that's a good one this guy's a
good one Zac Higgins at Zac what is it
kickings thoughts on people that
continue jogging in place when they're
waiting in traffic I always [ __ ] think
about that when I see these people do it
stop jogging for a second all right what
is it if what do you who you uh what's
his name [ __ ] no is it Richard Simmons
so under the oldies who what do you stop
for a second it's actually better to
stop cuz then your heart rate goes down
and then you get it go back up again you
don't have to keep the heart rate go and
while you're jogging in place waiting
for three seconds to the light to change
or you know what how about this run the
other way and it's always a guy in a
[ __ ] tank top with short shorts
always a guy every time I see people
jogging they don't look that fit except
in LA in LA dude you'll have like he-man
jogging down the street on Sunset
Boulevard if you jog down busy streets
wow you're a hoe you know dude you're a
hoe dude that's so funny to me that's a
good one good good good good call Zach
Kagan's it's a [ __ ] weird evil
villain named uh Zach Higgins all right
I'm gonna go you guys did a great time
we had a great time in this
congratulations didn't we
oh I'm gonna name I'm gonna name an
elder though that's what I'm gonna do
and here's what here
what I'm gonna do because he's helped
the podcast and he did it without even
really knowing now here's I'm gonna
tweet out a link here for you guys
afterwards you know what [ __ ] link
I'm gonna tweet out so he won fire can
be intro in charge of it I've been
talking about him a lot on my podcast
and he sent me emails and messages and
[ __ ] about my podcast and I'm gonna make
him an elder I'm gonna send him a pin
and a certificate and it's my uncle
Vinny he's an elder now the
congratulations podcast cult and I know
your address already so we're gonna just
send you that
so congratulations uncle Vinny you're an
elder now and I think I'm gonna problem
shooting myself in the foot with this
but however you're invited to the log
cabin and you're an elder and you're the
first family member that's an elder to
be honest I might have maybe gave Matt
one I'm not sure maybe Matt's it maybe
Matt's an elder but maybe that's an over
but my dad my mom my own dad my own mom
are an elder so uncle Vinny thanks for
your service on helping us with the
congratulations podcast by all your your
mean messages and emails your very legal
emails so we'll send that over to you
and then also oh also he has a he made a
website my cousin made a website which
will tweet out from my thing which is uh
the you can't actually buy this stuff I
don't believe but it's uncle Vinny what
is it I'm gonna look it up he's a
freakin insane person I swear to god you
guys are gonna howl though you gotta
check this out Richard he sent it to me
the uncle Vinny store.com VI n NY store
now none of this stuff is actually for
sale I don't think click on that click
on that no right no my cousin Evan made
this I believe you gotta bite to his guy
he sells to wallet clips from all the
[ __ ] he sells 100 Burke I got a look at
the
the actual site though it's pretty funny
must buy two of all home all right so
that's what's up so he's an elder now
we're gonna send it to you what's it say
haha Evans Instagram is down on the
bottom all right so uh square cash have
you switched yet
download the free square cash app and
two rewards code congrats and get five
dollars and give five dollars - times up
get it for iOS or Android now follow the
leader tour buy tickets at crystally
accom Denver Boise Eugene Houston
Wichita Kansas City Lincoln reading
Tulsa Midwest City Dallas Las Vegas
Portland Hampton Beach Mashantucket I'm
just naming a bunch of ones Red Bank
Sacramento Wilmington Delaware and we
got new merch socks new merchandise we
got socks up follow-the-leader socks and
also true baby socks true baby socks
with the pacifier honor subscribe to the
YouTube channel download the Chris
D'Elia app for iOS or Android I've been
posting on that type and Chris D'Elia in
the App Store crystally in the App Store
please subscribe rate and review the
show that really helps our rankings and
it gets I need you guys and need you
babies to spread the word every baby out
there text your friend that doesn't
listen to the podcast to listen to this
podcast I would love that and then you
would be doing your service for this
video episodes go up soon
man on fire check it out adding Netflix
checking on Netflix incorrigible or
whatnot black comic on composition calm
and that's it thanks for listening guys
and just remember I'm no Walmart comic
[Music]